You know, um, Donald Trump is not the caricature that they make him out to be.
And, you know, I, I just, I, I,
there are certain little vignettes that I remember, you know, when,
when my kids would be, we'd go, we'd fly down to Florida.
We had a house in the first he had Mar-a-Lago. Um, and,
and he would say very quietly to his kids.
Don't talk to her like that. You don't talk to your sister like that.
You don't talk to him like that never raised his voice. You know,
he was always serious. And then when he got a little more upset,
it would be no, no emotion. You just lost your allowance,
keep it up, keep it up.
He was always attentive to their behavior and how they acted toward each other.
[inaudible].
So let's, let's back up for a second because, because you know, Trump and I,
and a lot of my audience, you, you know,
a bit about my political evolution and that I was,
I was a Bernie supporter and a progressive and a lefty and all those things.
And.
I you're good.
You're a pro you're a pro I should be judged accordingly for all of those
things. Um,
but I know that there's a lot of my audience that I would say they don't
consider themselves conservative per se, or even on the right.
But they consider themselves what I would say is sort of the disaffected
liberal. And I think that is a huge, huge amount of people in America right now,
the liberals that just can't believe how bananas the left has gone.
But I think the other piece of that is they just find something
about Trump. Off-putting whether it's the way he speaks or the tweeting or,
or whatever, something like that.
So since you know him and you talk about it a little bit already, can you just,
if you wanted people to be more okay, that, that he does love this country,
that he's a decent guy and it took me a long time to get there, by the way,
I think I mentioned this on your show. It wasn't until I actually met him.
And I had about 10 minutes to talk to him that I felt more. Okay. Um,
when he, when he literally turned to my husband and I, and he goes,
you guys are gay. He goes, that's great.
Your only problem is you're too handsome. And I thought,
this is the guy who says, everyone's a home. You know, they,
they say he thinks that he's a homophobe. Um,
but since you know him a little bit more, yeah. Can you.
Dive into that? You know, um,
Donald Trump is not the caricature that they make him out to be. And, you know,
I just, I, I, there are certain little vignettes that I remember, you know,
when, when my kids would be, we'd go, we'd fly down to Florida.
We had a house in the first, he had more Lago. Um, and,
and he would say very quietly to his kids.
Don't talk to her like that. You don't talk to your sister like that.
You don't talk to him like that never raised his voice. You know,
he was always serious. And then when he got a little more upset,
it would be no, no emotion. You just lost your allowance,
keep it up, keep it up.
He was always attentive to their behavior and how they acted toward each other.
And, and I I'll never forget. It was, it was sort of the beginning of, of, of,
uh, school or, uh, no, the second semester, I guess. And he said, uh,
when we land, we're going to K-Mart to get our school supplies.
You said to the kids, and I'm like, Donald Trump goes that Kmart. Wow.
When we would walk down the street in Manhattan, we went out with him a lot. Um,
he was always kind to me, he would say to people, you know, this Janine Bureau,
she's the da, you know, from Westchester.
And I was always on television for something. And, um,
and he was always more, um, you know,
it was beholding and try and get people to recognize you. Instead of him,
whenever he saw a cop, whenever he saw a construction worker or a hard hat,
and they were all enamored with him, they were like, Oh, hi.
And then they didn't have phone cameras maybe back then, but they say,
can I shake your hand? He would absolutely do it.
Whenever we go into a restaurant and have dinner or something,
you'd March right into that kitchen and take care of everybody in the kitchen.
He is a good, generous man.
And his kids are a Testament to the success,
uh, that he instilled in them. Every one of them. I mean, those kids are smart.
They're successful. They're brilliant. They really are. And as a human being,
you know, you go through tough periods in your life or your career.
He was always there for me, or, you know, for my then husband,
he was always there, always generous in spirit,
loved his brother. Robert. I was at the white house for the, uh, uh,
for the week, uh, was very, very sad about that.
Uh, very family-oriented day. They were always together.
He was with his sisters and his brother, um, and never drank.
And I remember when I interviewed him in 2016, right before, um,
he ran, uh, it was, there was talk of him running. And I said,
you want to tell people you don't drink? He said, no, I don't drink,
never had a drink. And people were floored by that,
but I've seen him in parties all hours of the day and night go tomorrow,
Lago everybody be, you know, half in the bag, not Donald Donald.
I love the guy. He's, he's a wonderful, wonderful man.
And he loves this country. And you know what? I don't know anyone, Dave,
who could take the assaults that he's taken on a daily basis and survive
them. The guy looks better than ever, usually after four years, you're,
you're exhausted. He's raring to go.
I know he's, he's more bronze than usual now. It's, it's very,
it must be because of peace in the middle East, it made him bronze or something.
But, but speaking of the, the human side of things,
I've had a bunch of the Fox hosts on, and you know,
you guys all just get endlessly trashed in the media and you get the
media matters boycotts, and they go for your sponsors and all of that stuff.
And I don't know how comfortable you comfortable.
You you'll be talking about this,
but you did mention to me once how it can take a toll, you know, when you're,
when you're in your town and Oh,
there's judging and she's on Fox and just dealing with some of,
some of that kind of hate. And yet you always have a smile on your face. I mean,
what, what's that like? Just, just being, you, you live in New York,
you you're a public person and you got to deal with some,
some pretty hateful stuff.
Yeah, I do. I do. But you see the difference for me is, um,
I ran for office five times. I am hardened with steel, uh,
and, uh, I'm used to it. I mean, I used to boy copy for this or that,
or I'd prosecuted case. They didn't like it. Or, uh, you know, you know what,
I really don't care if you care enough that,
uh, you're thinking about changing your mind, then care and change your mind.
But if you're, if you believe that what you're doing is right,
I don't give it a second thought, but what I am amazed, uh,
at, or with is the fact that people on the left dropped me.
You know, when Trump got elected, my friends dropped me and I was like,
but I would never drop you. You know, I, I just wouldn't,
it all started, you know, we all got dropped and I, I found that hurt.
That hurt It hurt. And you know,
when you try, you know, to, to, to not maybe sound as crazy,
and then you just say, you know what, I am who I am. It's a short visit here,
Dave, all of us are here for a short time. And if you,
if you can't be who you are, and if you don't know who you are,
then you better, you know, re-introduce yourself to yourself and get moving.
So I have, I have no regrets and I also don't worry about those people.
Uh, and I also am a gun owner. I have six guns.
Uh, as you know, I am an, I am a new gun owner. So, uh, we,
we share some things in common. So you end the book, uh,
fittingly with the closing statement. So I feel that we should end this, uh,
interview with a closing statement. I mean,
if someone picks up your book and we're six weeks now, roughly,
but when the book comes out about five weeks before the election,
what is it that you want them to take more than anything else from the book?
I want people to recognize that, uh, it is,
it's not just about the lies. I mean,
I identify the lies and I go through the lies,
but the most important thing for them to understand is that there's a quote from
Abraham Lincoln, uh, from his speech at Lyceum,
where he talks about the destruction of this country will not come from a
foreign source. It will come from within,
and that's what we're facing right now. We're facing an absolute,
um, destruction of America. As we know it from forces within America.
And we can't let that happen.
We're more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of nonstop
yelling. Check-out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.